hello i'm jamie campbell bower and
stupidly i'm here with buzzfeed to read
some first tweets god help me
[Music]
right okay here we go tap to reveal i
need jamie campbell bower to read first
tweets but not mine
too late we're here we're doing it so
it's happening imagine going out with
jamie campbell bauer imagine your
boyfriend being prettier than you that
would suck oh well first of all we're
all beautiful and thank you for calling
me pretty second of all got any dresses
i can borrow beckner is so sexy i want
him so bad what's wrong with you come on
pull it together man's got tendrils and
a big left hand maybe that's what you're
into i don't know
mental
i had a sex dream and jamie campbell bow
was the object of my desires so that's
cool hey it's my body get it out of your
mind take me for dinner
[Laughter]
good lord vegan looks so [ __ ] sexy in
that i'm not even joking come here my
butt you really you like all caps all
caps like you're not even really a
cohesive sentence there you're really
like something's going on there i mean
appreciated oh my goodness good lord i
want to slam jamie campbell bauer
against the door and make out
passionately and have rough sex
afterwards there i said it
i mean you know what you want i'll tell
you that much you definitely know what
you want
thank you
i guess thanks
cheers good god to be honest i
understand vetner's motivations because
if i went from looking like a hot piece
of ass to that i would be mad so
it goes a little deeper than skin deep
but um i mean i kind of like the vines
the nails are great there's a good nail
salon in the upside down i'm telling you
me sees jamie campbell bow a photo on
phone me lick screen well i mean that's
just dangerous i hope that you keep your
phone in a safe and sanitized place at
all times because otherwise
you're going to be getting hickeys i
will never be fully satisfied with my
life until i lick jamie bauer
i'm not a lollipop i'm a person i would
never call anyone daddy unless it's
jamie campbell bauer oh my god i'm on my
knees he's so hot oh
oh
not even your own father i'm not your
father i'm not your dad
i'm also
get up off your knees it's dirty on the
floor the guy who's vectoring stranger
things that's me is so effing hot
please wechner
you've been watching the wrong show
there's no
vectors having sex with anyone in the
show i'm not choosing people to have sex
with i'm literally killing them if you
if you think that that's what sex is you
need to call me and we'll have a long
talk okay because
oh my god where do you find these people
god
[Laughter]
no shame no shame thinking about what it
would be like to turn up in your bed and
see vector first thing when you wake up
does he moan does he squelch wetly does
he get his coffee before or after the
wet squelching
i have questions
i like you've really thought about this
joe does vec nimon well absolutely it's
more of a sort of low grown does he
squelch wetly
well
between you and i joe he does
he does
he's a very s welchy man does he get his
coffee before or after the wet
squelching now this is interesting
because this to me sounds like you have
personal experience of
of a of a pre squelching coffee
dear jamie campbell bower can i just
suck your hand
how big is your mouth
wechner
your time has come
me
to spank me daddy
jesus
good lord
there's a level of air that just seems
to land after each one of these which is
getting progressively
heavier
um
wow
i'm sorry
i'm just sorry
i'm sorry thank god vecna isn't real
because what if i start moaning while
he's sucking the life out of me
[Laughter]
wait
there's so much to that that's that's
really that's a very smart tweet because
that's multi-layered i want vegna to
blow my back out and destroy my insides
daddy i wonder how many people
from the netflix team are on this zoom
and having to listen to this right now
because i'm so sorry everyone dear jamie
campbell bower
bite me
punched me in the face
[Music]
spit on me
run me over with the bus
curb stomped me break every bone in my
body please and thank you and i love you
wow wow that's a lot
that is a lot there's a lot of visuals
there for me to kind of process i'm a
very visual person and that's um
it's just
kind of upsetting actually if i'm being
totally honest i'm kind of sad
um
i love you you'll be alright we'll get
through this holy jesus
my god
i feel like i'm in high school i feel
like i'm back at school
not that this happened at school but
there's a weird feeling on the inside
nobody told me jamie campbell bow was in
stranger things until now
oh my god i've wanted to suck that man
up since 2013.
it's a shorter period of time than i've
been trying to stop my own self off
so
[Laughter]
so you know
me first thanks i feel like i've gone
19 rounds
with mike tyson
it's been
an absolute disaster
thank you so much for all your weirdness
i love it and i appreciate it and please
don't forget to go and watch volume 2 of
stranger things the v-mans out there
thanks
[Music]
right
[Music]